you think inflation goes up from here uh
yeah i mean
if so it's not scheduled to let me let
me ask this question in the most stupid
wonky economist way possible
there's a high probability that it
decelerates and starts to decelerate um
we're starting to get to the point in
the process particularly once you get to
march where inflation the base effects
really start to kick in and so you need
to see
in substantial acceleration in the
current trend growth rate of inflation
the sequential rate of inflation to
maintain the same level of inflation on
a year over year basis now that doesn't
necessarily mean
that
once inflation starts coming down on a
year over year basis that inflation is
under control
you could be sort of maintaining the
same very elevated level of inflation
sequential per you know momentum um it's
just that the year over years are going
down because you know we already did it
last year basically and so i think that
is a high likelihood of occurring um
there was also there was a prior to
today and prior to oil you know
basically going from 90 pounds a pair to
100 those a barrel in one day
there was a high probability that we
were going to lose inflation momentum so
not only were we going to win on the
year of the year we were going to win on
the sequential and the momentum and the
fed would be able to say quicker sooner
that hey look we got this thing under
control
now it's a function of this move in
commodity prices because it's not just
crude oil
and more importantly what a war could do
in terms of tax in the productive
capacity of the economy like what if you
know we might not be sending a ton of
troops there what if germany and france
and a bunch of troops there you know
what if ukraine mobilizes and russia
before you know mobilizes more i don't
know there's a lot of things that could
happen that could actually you know sort
of really become an additional tax on
the productive capacity of the global
economy and if that is a if that occurs
then we're likely to see you know
something that looks more like what we
saw kind of in the fall this this most
recent year which is supply chain
disruptions and so if that continues to
happen then we're going to have a big
problem on the inflation front um that
would be a secondary problem relative to
what we already have inflation i believe
will if we continuously kind of step in
go to war i think it will get worse by
based off the amount of money that we're
gonna have to print totally but for the
fed it seems like
they don't have to raise rates right
like they would have i guess right so
they were expecting everyone from three
to nine yeah interest rate hikes but it
seems like it's almost being priced in
everything got overvalued a little bit
um it's kind of coming back to normal as
what we're seeing now right so are they
are they going to still raise in march
do you think
yeah no i i think again i think the fed
is it
the worst again i think i said this last
week
the the u.s economy is already sort of
on this
slow but
in my opinion deliberate road towards
recession right we've had persistent
real negative real income growth for
on a per capita basis for months now
and so you know how you can have a
economy growing on a real basis at all
in the absence of stimulus with that
dynamic is beyond me and beyond the math
of anybody operating excel or python or
any other program and so you know if the
fed did nothing
it was likely that we were going to have
an economy sort of just decay naturally
on its way to recession until we got
inflation under control until we had a
more uh better realignment of demand
with the productive capacity of the
economy
the fed is
in order to control inflation is
effectively trying to speed that process
up right you know they think they have
the ability to sort of get us right to
the brink of recession just enough to
get inflation to control but then to
make this perfect pivot and you know get
us
stave off recession and make sure that
the labor market doesn't doesn't take it
on the chin
the history is very very unkind to the
fed and their ability to do that and i
think they probably get better every
time right they're more responsive
there's more data there's more people
there's more twitter there's more
everything there's more information
right so they're probably going to be
better at it than
they have been historically but that
doesn't mean they have the ability to
turn the us economy on a dime to turn
the global economy on a dime there's all
these dynamics that happen in terms of
credit creation off-balance sheet in the
shadow finance sector and non-bank
entities you know that the fed doesn't
necessarily have a real true control
over they have signaling power over but
they don't necessarily have true control
over so
i just it's kind of wrapping this up i
think the the key risk here is that
we could slide into recessions albeit on
a slower pace
if the fed does nothing
and loses his credibility in the process
or we could slide towards recession or
even into recession if the fed does
something to bring in inflation to me i
think the first outcome longer term is
much worse
because once the central bank loses
credibility
s p goes from i don't know 4 000 to 1
000.
like right now so much of the s p 500
valuation is a function of the fed
having credibility right and if the fed
just loses credibility on inflation and
its ability to control the business
cycle then i think there's a lot of
valuation premium in u.s assets in
particular
that is at risk